[Music]
now make sure you check that our I we
sound more like a stage always see yeah
I probably make a lot of noise right now
[Music]
just make sure this is a safe space for
me my body positive here everyone okay
with me being gender fluid
I'm biologically a male but my boys in
high school identified me as a [ __ ]
[ __ ] either fluid not consensual
needs to be consensual oh it's my doctor
my doctor was like haunt your liver is
failing I was like dude don't body shave
me
just cuz I know how the liver of a white
sis male doesn't mean it's failing
could it be you should change your
definition of a liver today what I'm
going through
my name is Han skin that's my real name
it's not a stage name I was like how do
I get audiences look about North Korea
and the Nazis in electroform County my
parents they'd be moms because they
don't want kids at school to make fun of
me for having an Asian name so mission
accomplished through the right end of
the radar that no ideas Asian we're
supposed to be smart a lot of people
don't believe that my name is hot I was
that Starbucks lady was like what's your
name I was like Hans she's like okay
okay oh yeah you got me I'll give you my
name it's a real Asian they're ready for
it it's chicken chow mein ball in the
third come from a long line of big box
and I look like a dingdong but
my friends at school they would say
stupid things my friend suppose like
dude you got such an Asian smile I was
like thanks now we get to think about
how I'm physically different from
everyone around me every time I feel
happiness
I might have a funny name by the dick is
even funnier that I have a white friend
named Tanner would and should be like
hey this is my Mexican friend Tanner
that's what black for tennis let's not
race is not your suffixes I loved being
Asian because whenever people are racist
to me I just had confused I'm like why
you hate respectful people who keep to
themselves okay good luck finding an
affordable car I'm doing the best I know
up Christian as an Asian person which is
kind of different because the people who
wrote the Bible didn't even seem to know
that ages existed they can even drop us
a line an agent is great job with the
fireworks really proud of you back to
the Jews just all Jews the whole thing I
am an atheist now because I'm not in
kindergarten and I have an internet
connection
I think it'd be stressful to have a
world maybe like you've been destroyed
by facts just like walking down the
street I don't understand the super
religious people before like it's Adam
and Eve not Adam and Steve cuz I don't
think if it makes sense Adam and Eve
gave birth to Cain and Abel and Cain
murdered Abel what are you taking a
relationship advice from people who
raised a murderer he's a sociopath
really three other people he's like I
can't handle this
[Laughter]
to kill a quarter of the world's
population [ __ ] I have a lot of gay
friends my gay friend was like dude
you're so lucky you're not gay can you
imagine if most of the gender that you
were attracted to wasn't attracted to
you back I was like
we've so therefore I
you guys was crying constantly
justice I am single I have yet to find
my soulmate
I'd be anything maybe a chair apologies
I get out more it seems like a loser I
think I can do better I love women
that's my fetish I think they got the
best genitals in the human race
definitely in the top two holiday I can
ever [ __ ] a dude I've never looked at a
beautiful woman and been like yeah she's
alright but is there a version of her
that's bigger and hairier and there's
less kindness people are like Holly
should learn how to talk to girls maybe
or maybe girls should learn how to
listen to Hans I don't wanna hear about
the Federal Reserve this girls like hots
my vagina's the 3d printer isn't that
pretty cool I was like that's not even
accurate
[Laughter]
your womb was a 3d printer your vagina's
the tray it's not even a very good 3d
printer only prints one thing with lots
of errors takes nine months to print the
whole time is printing is complaining
[Laughter]
printers that night
I'm glad women give birth and but men
don't because I feel like if we gave
birth we'd go ahead bro I'm eating so
much protein creatine during my
pregnancy this papers like 27 pounds
ready bro talk about those gains in the
first trimester check out aspects of
ultrasound so III think you will work
out here it's like it's something I
really hate because I'm insecure and I
hate people who are stronger than me
this is 2017 we don't even need lips
anymore why are you tracking the biggest
limb while you're in the gym working out
there's a nerd in the basement clearing
out your bank account
what are you go study some math so he
stopped getting [ __ ] up Oh deals at
GNC
making yourself with a better person
you're making yourself with this shitty
orangutan service area for cancer now I
was bullied a lot
okay I don't understand people for anti
PC who think it's okay to say hurtful
words like [ __ ] or [ __ ] but then
they get really offended when you call
them racist or sexist because it's a
little [ __ ] now sorry I described a
part of your personality that's optional
and you can change go do that a lot of
people are like banned immigrants
immigrants are the worst I can't agree
more they're terrible people that was
like stop smoking wait go clean your
room move out of my basement
my country you move out Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]